hi there i'm sitting in the green cafe
in la vie
and i have a had a fascinating lunch
with ivan
right yes and we met in bratislava at
the polyglot conference
and he lives in kiev and lo and behold
he said i'm going to be in la viv and
let's get together and we can have a
little bite or something so that's what
we do and i have to say that i'm
tremendously impressed with ivan's
obviously russian ukrainian our native
languages and then french spanish and so
forth so
several things i'll say first of all
it's very interesting when we met in
bratislava
i couldn't say a word in ukraine
and now four or five days later i can
speak ukrainian because it was there
somewhere but as ivan himself said
you can't just turn it on sometimes you
need
a little bit of time to kind of you know
warm it up maybe two or three days and i
say that if you've if you learned the
language before so if you study it to a
sufficient level right then you go to
the country you're going to have those
two to three days and then things are
going to work exactly
so tell us yourself tell us a little bit
about what you do
uh what i do basically i'm island abroad
i'm a language coach i'm basically
helping people to learn foreign
languages and also to become themselves
through foreign languages that's what
i've been working on so i speak seven i
think i'm pretty pretty much those are
english french spanish italian and
basically all the ones that we we share
together right basically our common
languages um i've been to 22 countries
so i travel quite a bit i'm writing a
blog and i'm working on new courses for
english spanish primarily for russian
speakers so people who are kind of your
primary sort of target is russian
speakers largely in ukraine but also in
russia or belgium
right in all the let's say posts
because of mine and yeah that's that's
how it's okay
wait
there
[Music]
is
um
a
foreign
[Music]
anyway
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay bye for
now yeah there are lots of people like
ivan around the world and i think people
don't want to say oh gee he's very good
he's very down i think the one
impression i got at the meeting in both
there's so many people who speak so many
languages and it's just a matter of
putting in the time and the effort and
you'd be surprised at what you can
achieve yeah because you never know you
just have to try
okay
[Music]
you